um I was I brought up that six minutes
record you had with Wayne you that
record came out right around the time
when I feel like Wayne was like
making that transition from being the
dude we knew from like the hot boys and
like lights out waiting to being like
Carter one Carter two Wing where he
really kind of was like
finally getting rid because for a long
time I feel like people didn't give a
lot of the Cash Money guys respect as
rappers and then I think Carter one
changed that whole trajectory for Wayne
what was that record like because that's
a record where everyone's just kind of
going in
um
what what year was that was that 06
um over six minutes when that game six
because that was on your second album
yeah so oh five yeah oh 506. so yeah
that's like legit like right after
Carter one so what was that like was it
did you guys get in for that was that
like a very competitive session
yeah it came through um I was in New
York and Wayne came through
I was in the studio with Fab a lot back
then yeah and I mean came through
the studio also an amazing punchline
rapper some of the greatest lines ever
for sure like we really locked in we we
wasn't really like sending records or
nothing like that like they came through
the studio we really locked in and made
it happen and I I was I was the one that
put that record together like it wasn't
like a label thing or something like
that like because you were tapped in
with what was going on with Wayne yeah
and I knew Wayne was
um rapping at the time and I knew that
Fab was rapping at the time so if all of
us came and went crazy like that
no hook I don't gotta even be about no
hook trying to make a hit record I know
he could do that that's easy but
just talking about spitting and I knew
that to make make a mark so that's why I
wanted to put that record together is
that a competitive session
like who's like like I can only imagine
because you know nowadays people send
records out you hear a verse you put
your verse on it you send it back I
can't imagine all three of y'all in
there
just rapping yeah I think ever since I
came out I just changed the trajectory
of how was going like I made it
more competitive made you had to be more
lyrical made you have to have more punch
lines and lyrics and peace up more
syllables just to sound like you were
spitting right because before you ain't
have nothing else to compare it to but
when you could listen to me doing it
like this if you supposed to be lyrical
you gotta be doing it to a certain level
so around that time I came out you
started to see a lot of people change
more punch lines peace and no more
syllables changing they flow not trying
to be exactly like me but knowing that
you had to go in that direction to be
successful yeah for sure I mean you guys
also kicked I feel like there was that
wave after I'm a hustler where everybody
wanted that same type of hook yeah and
then bring them out came out because I'm
a hustler was first yeah but you kicked
off like a whole second wave of like
everyone hitting Swiss for like the
Jay-Z sample like hook yeah I'm a
hustler and I feel like it inspired a
lot like even the 50 record I Get Money
I Get Money like it's like the same
drums the same bounce the same beat the
same concept there was a lot of Records
like that yeah it might not have been a
Hove sample but they're like I feel like
that record kicked off a like a little
mini era for sure yeah for sure